so I like gain the respect everybody in
the gym everybody started to love me and
after that month my mom was like you
know I'm not gonna help you anymore I
guess really there's no need for me to
help you you need to figure your life
out I really think you should go back to
school I think you should give up on
this whole CrossFit think oh man I had a
lot to think about and I think what
really started to happen was I just was
running out of money and I didn't know
what to do anymore
so I had to come to grips with my
friends and tell them like hey I don't
have any money and I might have to drive
all the way home to New Jersey to my
mom's house go back to school and do
something I potentially don't even want
to do so there was this girl she's like
you know what you can sleep on my couch
if you want for as long as you need to
get on your feet and but I had never
talked to this girl in my life and I
originally turned it down and then got
to the point where I had to move all my
stuff out of my house and I was living
in and I sold all my stuff and I had
slept in my car for like a week and I
was like I can't do this this doesn't
right you know so during that week
actually I was when I started to steal I
started stealing like food and groceries
and stuff from the grocery store because
I wanted to stay and I didn't have any
money
Ryan Fischer in the building how are you
man super excited it's been it's been a
long time coming it's been a very long
time coming mean you've missed each
other like three different times time
zone problems but I've got you have
locked you down how's the bicep how's
the injury oh well actually that is
coming along I have like maybe three
more weeks until I can kind of cut loose
but right now it's been poof it's been
one hell of an experience I've never had
to stay so diligent about something for
so long like I've literally had to like
do nothing for two months and then after
that it's been very very light weights
for the last like month and I'm just
like dying to get after it again but I
think it was I think it's been good for
me though because I've been I've been
getting after it for such a long time
but they have a little bit of a break so
I good you've probably given other bits
of your body a rest as well yeah yeah
it's interesting I've had a little bit
of an injury as well and one thing there
was a question that's come through in my
mind was what who are you without your
fitness you know without that endorphin
kick every single day it's like being on
a drug for all your life and someone
taken away for me it was more like my
whole life is fitness in terms of like
my business and like things that I sell
and everything and like I feel like me
looking good is part of all that and
just like it kind of gave me a little
bit of stress and anxiety and then I was
like oh wait a second like all the stuff
that you've made you've you've already
made you don't like need to currently
look amazing in this exact moment and
then like there's other things that you
want to do that have nothing to do with
that and I've spent this entire time
kind of focusing on those things and I
don't think I would have gotten as far
into some of these other projects that I
have if it wasn't for the injury it's a
good way to kind of force fitness out
with your life for a little bit and give
you give you time to focus on other
stuff right yeah for sure
Coleman so first off how would you
describe what you do someone says hey
hey friend I've met you at an event what
are you to tell me who you are what do
you do that's funny because I get that
question a lot because everybody knows
that I do a lot of things so I'm always
like [ __ ] hmm I guess I guess I tell
everybody that I guess the short part
would say I'm a fitness entrepreneur but
usually I say I own a bunch of Fitness
companies and I own a social media
agency that's usually what I say so I do
have books that I sell that do very very
well so there's but there's probably
like almost ten different books that I
sell like daily and then I have my earn
your carbs challenge which is it used to
be the carb cycle challenge and then the
keto cycle challenge and now I'm just
turning it all into just the earner
carbs challenge and you get to pick
which way you want to go so if you like
high fat diets then keto psychos a way
to go if you like high carbs and heat or
the carbon cycle is the way to go and
you just pick it and I get these people
in a group on Facebook we do live q and
A's together they get all this
information I've created a website that
you put in your daily energy expenditure
and all the numbers and stuff pop up
it's custom to me and then they get
books and workouts and all sorts of
stuff and it's it's this it's this big
thing that I just did for fun for my gym
and I would post them on social media
on my CrossFit chalk Instagram because
that was my first gym was my CrossFit
gym and people were like I want to do
this challenge it looks really good and
I was like all right wall
why don't you venmo me or PayPal me and
then all of a sudden like all these
people were event rolling and PayPal him
and I was I couldn't keep up with it I
started I'd be sitting home on my phone
and I'd be like oh my god well this
person and not to let him into the group
and before I knew it I'd be on my phone
all day for like 2,000 bucks for the
month or something and I'd be like
there's got to be a better way to do
this so eventually I started to figure
out a better way to do that and now the
challenge is it's a little bit easier to
purchase and a little bit easier to
manage hmm but as I got better at that I
realized that there was a better way to
sell your products as well and I got
into like social media kind of marketing
and then from there I just created the
marketing agency that kind of helped me
in the beginning I had all those people
quit their job and then we kind of just
did it for other people yeah so now a
lot of my really good friends who are
like kind of big in the fitness industry
I run all their ads for them and I just
take a percentage of that of the sales
so that everybody seems to want to work
really really hard to get that person to
make money so in short a lot I create I
created that agency basically to help
other people
and then I have my stuff that's all
helping at the same time and then I run
my gym I run my I'm I live here in
Orange County California and I run my
gym every day and I run the Instagram I
run the instagrams for both is that you
you have an outsourced the Instagram to
anyone else nope Wow you know you get to
your sort of size of kind of workload
and sometimes you've got the the social
media assistant you dictate across the
room they put the post up or whatever I
have I have someone who does like
stories for it CrossFit jock and then
they'll answer some of the DMS but I
always make the post that's an
interesting take away for gym owners
there'll be a lot of gym owners
listening a lot of athletes listening
people who maybe have aspirations to own
their own facility eventually and it's
interesting that you've held on to that
sense of connection between you and
marking so with with the post for the
gym they're so important to me because
what you say is gonna resonate with
somebody on some level you might say
something like sometimes I'll talk about
like why we do hip thrusts and I don't
think that might person that works the
desk can you know really talk about hip
thrusts and like oh in a way that if you
will wanted to hit the rust I don't
think anyone can talk about hip frost in
a way that makes anyone want to do it
that's it like split squats man no one
wants to do split squats yeah but then
I'll also write like well hey like if
you you know do you follow CrossFit do
you follow choc online programming or
whatever if you don't then you know blah
blah blah and like I don't think
anyone's gonna want to take you know
pride and initiative into saying these
little things that kind of hook people
in so I always do the post and there's
definitely days that go by where I'm
just like I'm so fried on my own
Instagram that I just don't even do a
post it happens for sure I don't think I
made one yesterday my own Instagram is a
beast so it's like I'll answer at least
100 dm's a day I have I always do a post
no matter what I always do my stories no
one's ever answered a DM in my in my
Instagram I mean that's how we connected
right you know I'm a hustling you slide
into the DM z-- and we finally get the
date right for this so yeah I've got a I
got a friend George McGill who talks
about that he says the barbell strategy
for certain things like all in or all
out for a
lot of things get the people that do the
stuff that you're bad at to take that
over and then continue to double down so
yeah what I want to do I want to get I
want to have the definitive guide to
Ryan fish's life right I want anyone
that follows you online for the people
who don't you have an interesting very
interesting background and you hear
these stories on your Insur or social
media or whatever little separate bits
little chunks and that obviously sort of
ties people in but I want to hear I want
the full monty right I want start time
you tell us how we get to you being sat
here in front of me in Orange County how
where do you want to start let's start a
childhood man where are you from oh [ __ ]
all right cool
this might take a while by the way
that's what we here for but I'm good for
it
so childhood I lived in the Toms River
New Jersey it's a little beach town
central part of New Jersey all the way
in the East Coast it's obviously a lot
farther away than I am right now
and as I grew up I this is actually part
of the story is I always felt like there
was something wrong with me in my family
I grew up in a big family I had you know
I have I have five brothers and sisters
that I had lived with in a house but
then I have three other sisters from my
dad's side none of us have the same two
parents at any point I didn't know that
like realistically until I was like 18
and then I found out who my dad was when
I was 18 and then I met him when I was
24 and and when I actually met him it
made a lot of things in my life you know
make me understand a lot of things like
I genuinely as a kid was like I don't
get it I don't know why I'm here like I
feel like I wake up in the wrong family
every single day black sheep it was such
a strange feeling and it took until I
was 24 to figure out why I felt that way
and basically as I grew up I was always
just like a [ __ ] madman like I wanted
to I my mom bought me a bike one year
for Christmas and I just never put it
down like I would ride everywhere like I
remember hitting like flat tires on my
bike and having to call my mom and I at
the time I had this giant monstrosity of
a phone and it was like it was it was a
prepaid phone and I had like 10 minutes
on it and I'd call my mom and I beg hey
I'm all the way out here you need to
pick me up I got a flat tire and she be
like that's like a 35 minute car ride
which like I'm a 20 miles or something
on a bike would be like you know super
far and then she'd come get me and be
like what is wrong with you like you're
12 you don't have to drive your bike
this far and then I started to like
really get into it and then my mom was
like well maybe we should look into he's
obviously really good at riding his bike
so I started like BMX racing and that
was like my first my first like
addictive sport that I ever did and I
raced all over I was uh I was number 15
in the country most years that was like
my 10 to 15 range and then one year I
was number one and then I had to go to
Australia for World Championships but
nobody in my family really like flew
they're all kind of scared of flying so
I never went um on what a shame but even
just for fitting like to go to World
Championships I saw that I was like
thirty fifth in the world that year
which is pretty cool and then in the
high school I transferred like all that
riding and stuff kind of transfer it
into you know it's a pretty good cardio
so I started running track and
cross-country I also played football I
played lacrosse I did all the sports but
nothing really I never really loved
anything to the point where it's like
really likes you know sweep me off my
feet I did like track a lot but I had a
coach who he ran us so much that like I
wound up getting kind of like a little
bit of knee pain and it was a lot I was
running like 80 to 100 miles a week as a
young kid which is a lot I don't know if
you know that
by kilometers no no no when miles is
well man that's the only elbow you're on
the wrong side of the road you use in
Fahrenheit instead of Celsius but I'll
stick to the fact that you know that
miles is miles right all right
so from there I wound up thinking I was
gonna go be a pilot someday after all
the sports and everything I actually got
a really good scholarship to run at a
Ivy League school which is Cornell
University if you know who they are and
I turned it down because I was kind of
over running so then I was like I'm
gonna go be a pilot that sounds cool
that sounds fun it's right up my alley
you know it's kind of adventure kind of
junkie military military pilot or like
commercial stuff commercial stuff so I
actually moved too as soon as school was
over you know obviously I didn't really
like the way I felt in my family so I
went as far away as possible lived in
New Jersey and I lived in Hawaii so yeah
I got far away I went to pilot school I
got my helicopter license that was my
first first job so I was a helicopter
pilot and I kind of missed like doing
other things like I missed like working
out and I missed that that feeling so
one day I was actually just walking
through the dorms where I was living for
because I was going to school as well
and there was a sign that said you know
tryouts for bobsled and skeleton for the
US Olympic team or whatever in Hawaii in
Hawaii so they Verizon the phone company
they were going to every single state
all 50 states trying to recruit people
and and I see this sign and I was like
man that would be sweet you know so I
was like I just decided I was just gonna
go to tryouts and see how I did and I
went to the tryouts and I got like third
in the nation so it was humming having
never bobsled before no but the the
combine was a three rep max back squat
okay I wonder a 1 rep max power clean a
vertical jump
there was a sprint where they had timing
eyes and it would it would be 15 meters
30 meters and 45 and then there was an
underhand like medicine ball toss so
like out of all the numbers I had these
crazy scores I didn't even have any idea
that I was you know even when it was all
said and done I was like is that good
and they're like dude those numbers are
insane
so before I knew it like within like six
months I had flown out to Utah and lived
in Utah for about five years and
actually made it all the way up to like
potentially being on the Olympic team
and I hurt my hamstring and I never went
to the Olympics [ __ ] I know that's twice
know that you've got essentially next to
the top foot how well do you hear like
22 is that the age yeah around there
cool so that by the age of 22 you've got
to the top flight in two different
sports two very different sports ones on
ice ones on a bike and both times
through kind of no real error or
inability on your part you've just kind
of fallen short oh wow that transfer is
over again when I go to CrossFit so yeah
like what what was you talking like a
mute ah do you enjoy that I actually
hated it like why the entire time I
lived there I was like this is so boring
there's really nothing to do here I
lived in Park City which is a very small
town up in the mountains loads of
moments and I yep I mean you can
definitely feel the Mormon influence but
you know funny story is I didn't even
know what a Mormon was some one of the
guys on my team was like we were we were
training together he was a I started as
a skeleton athlete so headfirst that's
that that's the real scary one month
that's the Bulls to the old one I wasn't
big enough for bobsled yet I was only
like 165 pounds okay 160 hundred
sixty-five pounds I was pretty small at
the time and I don't know only thing I
qualify for was skeleton at that time so
in the beginning I started at skeleton
camp and was with these kids who all did
skeleton and this one kid who was really
really good he was telling me he was
gonna go on a mission and he's like hey
I'm going on a mission and I'll be but
I'm gonna be back I'll be gone for like
two years and I was like a mission like
going in the Marines and then you and
Tom Cruise and he's like no I'm Borman I
was like yeah but a mission is like
military stuff right and no and he's
like no he's like do you know where you
are right now and I was like no I have
no idea and then he tells me like what
more many people are because I had dude
I had no I thank God he told me though
because I went on some dates with some
girls where it made a lot of sense
[Laughter]
so after all that where am I now so I'm
in I'm in Utah yeah and then as I get
older now I look back and I'm like man I
really messed it up because Utah's a
really cool place there's all these
hikes to do that I'm into now and all
these great places to see and it's it's
it's an amazing place actually and at
the time I just I was one of those
people who was like a thousand percent
into something and didn't care about
anything else and I look back now and I
see the younger version of myself in my
gym the manager of my gym right now is
gross summer she's just she's so into
cross but it's the only thing that
matters and nothing else matters and I
get that like I was there for everything
I've ever done and I just think I'm like
manic if you two just brought in a
little bit more flexibility into your
life like you just liked a few other
things I think you'd be better because
there's years of my life that I almost
don't even remember because I was so
strict on my life like I didn't go out I
only ate this I only went to bed at this
time like I always worked out like
everything was so structured and I
didn't even care about anything else I
was like I don't give a [ __ ] I'm just
gonna be a machine until I just win
everything hmm
isn't it interesting so we love athletes
that are at the peak of the sport right
you look at someone like Eddie Hall
World's Strongest Man but he was adamant
that if he'd kept going for a couple of
years it had been divorced from his wife
and probably dead from a heart attack
but as the people for whom sport is
everything they've got or everything
they want they have to make those
sacrifices because if they don't you'll
get out competed by the Eddie hall of
bobsled or the Eddie Hall it's like
skeleton or whatever but you are right
like when you look back the benefit of
20/20 vision in hindsight is that you
can always think [ __ ] if I'd sacrifice
2% of that I could have benefited maybe
20% of life I could have gone gone done'
a hike i have a friend who lives in
newton out of her front door i saw this
video and it's just normal total normal
neighborhood but the backgrounds just
mountains like some Lord of the Rings
[ __ ]
oh my god that looks so amazing but
obviously for you you were like not head
down crack on and that's the sacrifice
you got to make but like you say with
with hindsight it's more challenging yes
I look back and I'm like I really wasted
years for sure but I mean it for me at
the time I would I would tell you that I
was happy and I was you know I was doing
what I love to do and that's really the
the trade-off I wonder as well if you
change that whether you would have been
happy you now in that life might have
been happy with the changer but you then
didn't want it all or you'd have done it
you know I mean no I don't think I would
have I think I I probably would have
been miserable I would have been like
you're taking me out of what I think is
best for me right now
[ __ ] you older Ryan younger Ryan is
doing there's there's such a different
definition of what happy is now it's
unreal so I guess from there I start to
realize that you know I don't want to do
this again for another four years right
the Olympic nobody gives a [ __ ] about my
sport until the Olympic year even World
Championships is like the exact same
thing as the Olympics and people don't
realize this but like the World
Championships that happen every year for
skeleton bobsled skiing snowboarding
everything is the same thing as the
Olympic year it's just that you don't
have the whole world watching and for us
for the sliding sports we like to call
them skeleton bobsled luge nobody was
there for World Championships nobody was
there for the national events like none
of that stuff so there was really no
allure during during that time so to
stick it up in our four years to
potentially get to that moment and
potentially get injured again or
something was very scary to me and I was
like no let's maybe just like going to
the military it's you know to go be a
pilot like I originally wanted to do or
I'll do something else like now that I'm
gonna you know this really great athlete
maybe I'll maybe I'll do like Special
Forces or something like that just
because to be in a helicopter doesn't
seem like it's probably best suited for
me at this moment so I started looking
into all the Special Forces branches
like the army the Navy Air Force all
this stuff and a friend of mine and said
you know you should really try doing
Crossfit I think that it's a great
training tool for anybody going the
military even if you're gonna go in and
be a pilot you still have to get through
boot camp and stuff and it'd be great to
have this under your belt so I I walk
into a CrossFit gym and the owner of the
gym his name is Tommy hackenbruck if you
know this is the year
I walk into his gym he had just gotten
2nd place in the CrossFit Games so I
didn't know who he was but as i walked
in i saw his eyes lock on me and he was
like oh this guy like he could just tell
this I was like really really fit from
bobsled and I think I was like almost I
was almost like 200 pounds at the time
and just jacked and my entire across the
career I've been probably 175 280 pounds
so I was a lot bigger than I than I am
now and I remember walking in and he saw
me and we had this intro class together
where he gives me like a we just do like
a pretty basic workout and there's five
other people that are there for this
basic workout as well and after the
workout I remember he's just looking at
me and he's like dude I need someone
like you to train with and I'm like well
I don't know how to do any of this stuff
I'm just here cuz I heard that this was
gonna be cool I want to go in the
military and he's like well you know if
if you agree to come at like certain
times like when I train you don't have
to pay for a membership and you know you
can help me train for events and I think
that I think this might be something you
really like is this in Utah this is in
Utah in Salt Lake City so I decided I
was no longer gonna do bobsled anymore
and I moved from Park City to the Salt
Lake City which is like 30 minutes down
a giant mountain that's the most like
Utah direction ever it's like go 3
minutes down the mountain you will find
the city the city is there and I'm
living in the city and I'm finishing my
degree at the University and I go to
this gym and I meet him so then we just
start training all the time and probably
within a few months I had articles about
me all over the place that I was like
this freak athlete and everybody was
excited to see me go to regionals and
excited to see me go to the games and
you could look up old articles I was
like The Dark Horse athlete and all this
stuff and it kind of gave me a big head
I was like oh yeah I'm gonna [ __ ]
crush this for you no so I went to my
first regional which would have been had
I gotten top 3 I would have went to the
CrossFit Games and it was almost like
everybody was like oh Ryan's definitely
getting top 3 and I went and I got
14 because I had absolutely no idea how
to compete like I was insanely good but
I had no idea what I was doing
like handstand push-ups for instance you
had to flip up on the wall and do a
handstand pushup
you know with your butt casing the wall
and I would lay on my stomach and walk
my stomach to the wall and I'd do
handstand push-ups because I was too
scared I was too scared to flip I had
never done that yet okay yeah and I saw
I saw the workout and the first workout
that really screwed me for the whole
thing was it was a thousand-meter run 30
handstand push-ups thousand-meter row
that's it which is such an he's such an
easy event now people would kill that
now it would be like 100 handstand
push-ups and then a thousand-meter row
so I get on the the wall and I walk
myself up and start doing handstand and
the guy's like dude no [ __ ] rap like
what he's like you have to flip up and
I'm like dude I'm like terrified so like
I try to flip up you know I had done it
at the gym a few times and I just never
liked the feeling but I got it done and
after that event I knew I was basically
Fox it out now I should just have fun
and just enjoy the moment and then after
that I was like well [ __ ] this like I've
[ __ ] the whole military thing I have
to come back and I have to own this you
know so the next year I came back to
regionals and I got fourth place [ __ ]
one outside one outside of the game and
it was because of what regional is Utah
it was Southwest at the time that was
the regional and but then I moved to
California because in my head I after
that second year after that first
regional I moved to California good so I
moved to California because I figured no
matter how the next year went and
CrossFit or whatever I still want to
feel into the military so all the Navy
SEALs and stuff we're training in San
Diego in California so I moved to San
Diego to train with military guys and
then during that time I kept I kept
doing my training for regionals and I'd
done a job at across the gym so I'm
moving out to San Diego I start training
and I go to the regionals and I want him
getting fourth place
which suck and the whole reason I got
fourth fourth place for this particular
bed I got top 5 in every single event at
Regionals I would have destroyed
regionals but one of the events I got
like 24th place because I didn't I
didn't know how to do a hang plane like
I had done power cleans and [ __ ] like in
my training but like doing hang power
cleans with 225 pounds to me was like
devastating cuz we had to do 30 of them
in a workout and I like could not hang
on to the bar so everybody was doing
like sets of 2 to 5 reps at a time and I
was doing like one at a time so that
went up getting fourth place and I was
like oh my god I was like [ __ ] this you
know so after this time after that that
year that's when things like really
start to change for me this is when I
really start to figure out who I'm going
to be and what my future is gonna be
because after regionals obviously I want
it to be a complete maniac and just be
the most diligent person you've ever
seen in your life and just crush
everything but I was having problems at
work and I hated the gym that I worked
at the girl who owned it was running it
more like a bootcamp and across the gym
and I was a die-hard crossfitter I
wanted to see lifting in the workouts
not just like long met cons every day I
wanted to see you know skill work I
wanted to see like true CrossFit so we
bumped heads a lot and eventually I got
to the point where I was like you know
what I don't respect you as a gym owner
like I don't like what you're doing it's
not it's not the right way you guys
hired me to do a job let me do it and it
was she's a female so you tell a female
you don't respect her it doesn't work
out very well I didn't like
theoretically tell her I respect her I
told her like I actually don't respect
you as a human and she just lost it
so like anyone getting in this big fight
and I was like you know what [ __ ] you I
quit anyway I don't care whatever and
she had three partners and her three
partners were begging me to stay so I
tried to stay for like a couple more
weeks but I'd see her every day and I
was like I can't do this it's like
walking on eggshells at work I don't
like it so I have about $5,000 maybe
saved up so I quit about two months went
by
my $2,000 a month rent and now I have
like a thousand bucks left but not
really a thousand the guy had spent
money on food and gas and you know
living my life so I got with a couple
hundred dollars left and I had written
emails to every Jim in town that I want
a job I I had applied for a million
different jobs I had two internship
opportunities one with Stanford and one
with Notre Dame because I had done
really well in school and I could have
went and become a strength conditioning
an assist in strength conditioning coach
but it was non pay for like nine months
or something and I didn't have any money
so I called the schools and I was like
hey I want to take this internship but I
need at least like give me housing give
me a give me like a student athlete meal
plan give me something that I can live
on and none of them were willing to do
anything so I had to turn down these
amazing opportunities so from there I'm
just like basically like [ __ ] I don't
know what I'm gonna do this sucks and I
had gotten a membership a very
discounted membership it was like two
dollars a month but these guys let me
work out for like $30 a month at this
gym called Pacific Beach CrossFit and
that's where I met a man named Anders
Varner and another guy named Brian
Borstein who Anders Varner now I'm my
podcast is on his network barbell shrug
so when I first met him you know they're
going off my resume and my resume says
you know I just got in fourth place at
Regionals I was a helicopter pilot I was
on the Olympic bobsled team like a freak
yeah I have my degree in exercise
physiology a degree in nutrition you
know all these different things and my
friend is like dude this guy is gonna be
intense
and then like I walk in the gym and you
know we do a workout together and
they're like holy [ __ ] this guy is cool
you know like they really liked me and I
but I just got done telling him I had no
money and like the reason I hit him up
is because you know I just want to place
the train so they were like whoa dude
you can train here like you know you
can't train here for free but you can
train here for you know like $30 or
whatever it was really really cheap so I
was like all right cool I didn't I
couldn't even afford that and like after
a big like this next month my mom might
have given me money for rent because I
remember still having a house
Levin are you still has his son Diego
still this Jim I'm still in San Diego
yeah so I like gain the respect
everybody in the gym everybody started
to love me and after that month my mom
was like you know I'm not gonna help you
anymore I guess really there's no need
for me to help you you need to figure
your life out I really think you should
go back to school I think you should
give up on this whole CrossFit thing and
I don't really like the idea of the
military and like all these different
things so man I had a lot to think about
and I think what really started to
happen was I just was running out of
money and I didn't know what to do
anymore so I had to come come to grips
with my friends and tell them like hey I
don't have any money and I'm I might
have to drive all the way home to New
Jersey to my mom's house and then go
back to school and do something I
potentially don't even want to do so
everybody in the gym was like
heartbroken over this so like no way
like not Ryan like blah blah blah we
want him to stay and there was this girl
named Erin Dwyer and she's like you know
what you can sleep on my couch if you
want for as long as you need to get on
your feet and but I had never talked to
this girl in my life she just like
everybody seems to like you you know I'm
a nurse I'm not home all that much and
you know it's there for you and I
originally turned it down and then got
to the point where I had to move all my
stuff out of my house but I was living
in and I sold all my stuff and I had
slept in my car for like a week and I
was like just was like I can't do this
this is not this doesn't right you know
so during that week actually I was when
I started to steal I started stealing
like food and groceries and stuff from
the grocery store because I wanted to
stay and I didn't have any money why did
you turn it down originally why did you
turn her off the dome was it pride
no definitely not I was definitely like
willing to take people's help it was
just that I didn't realize I was that
far down yeah like where like that was
what I needed you know I kept I always
in my mind I'm like such an optimistic
guy and I'm always like pretty pretty
bubbly I always feel like everything's
gonna work out you know but like it was
that one moment where I was like dude
it's [ __ ] not gonna work out you've
been in Utah for a week you've been yes
to him stuff from Whole Foods like you
got to take the couch yeah so and it was
also like weird cuz I didn't know her it
was like I genuinely
I didn't take classes with her I didn't
work out with her like I didn't know her
at all like I know her I knew her is
about as long as we know each other on
this podcast so I was like alright you
know I'm gonna do it and I wound up
sleeping on her couch for like four
months there's a long time and it was a
very embarrassing time like to wake up
every day just knowing that you're like
in somebody's space and they probably
thought you were gonna be there for like
maybe a month and now it's like four
months yeah so that started to feel very
very shitty and I'll never forget during
that whole time I'll never forget what
it was like to go to bed so like every
single night when I would go to sleep it
would just be like full anxiety just
like why are you even sleeping like you
don't have anything together like you
have no reason to wake up tomorrow
rather than to wait than to work out
like you're a [ __ ] bum like what are
you doing you know what I mean like it
and it it really like crushed my soul
like every day I was like man like I
looked at my resume and I was like this
is who I am but like this is where I'm
at right now and I don't understand it
and it was it was hard man it was really
hard to sleep it was really hard to just
like want to show up the next day
but I kept showing up and doing what I
did best at the time and this is when I
really feel like you know when you when
all else fails like just keep doing what
you love and there'll be a way that it
works out everybody in the gym at the
time had kind of signed me up for this
competition called the O so you throw
down and it was
besides the CrossFit Games it was the
biggest profit event in the world and
you would do these workouts and you
would tape your your workout you'd put
it online and then you'd get placed you
know first to a thousand or whatever and
getting invites was like all the top
athletes in the world like all the best
crossers if you'd been to the games you
got a an official invite to this
competition but a lot of them still had
to do the open online workouts I got
second in the world on these online
workouts and it was the first time
anybody had ever seen me workout who had
it been to regionals
so like social media wasn't that big yet
like just sorry I think Instagram had
like just started so I would go crush at
Regionals and the only people who would
know me are like you know the local
crowd but now the whole world knew who I
was and they're like wow this guy's
insane and like at the time I never
worked out in shoes I always worked out
barefoot because I had one pair I had
like one good pair of shoes and I didn't
want to ruin them so I'd always just
take them off so like all of my old
videos i'm i'm back squatting everybody
was really into the twenty right back
squat back then and I'd be I'd be doing
20 right back squat and like like 365
period and seventy-five pounds and I'm
barefoot and like one sweaty feet on a
slippy floor there was one time I did
335 and I lost count so instead of 20 I
did like 30 reps and I have all these
things like recorded and I would start
putting them on Facebook and people are
like this guy is insane cuz like no one
had had numbers like that in CrossFit
like yeah like strongman and all that
I'm sure it was going on everywhere but
in CrossFit man I was snatching 275 when
like 225 was cool and like I was back
squatting 500 pounds when 365 was cool
like I was so beyond the numbers and
then all of a sudden I started throwing
down like insane met cons I was doing
Fran in under two minutes you know I was
doing grace in like a minute you know it
just crazy crazy things like everything
was unbroken I was like two minutes
faster than everybody on Helen just
crazy stuff so everybody was really
really excited to watch me go to those
Heathrow time and actually compete and
then I get my letter that says hey you
know welcome to the throwdown and you
know you gotta sign this out like fill
this out and then pay and it was $200
and I was like $200 I was like there is
no way I can go to this so I never I
just I just let it go and I get a phone
call like a month later from the guy
who's throwing the event and he says hey
like you never filled out the thing
everybody wants to see you and I'm like
dude I'm really embarrassed to tell you
this but like I am legitimately like I
have nothing I'm sitting on some girl's
couch there's I don't I to be honest
I've been stealing food for like four
months like I said
have nothing I'm like that like the no
shoes that you see in the videos it's
not a joke that's like real lunch it so
he's like well alright I understand your
situation let's just we'll copier your
we'll make it free for you and if you
win you just pay me back and I'm like
alright cool
you know it's like it all excited oh my
god I'm gonna go to this big event this
is gonna be crazy
hmm so I went to the big event and I'm
still sitting on the couch did you have
shoes by this point borrowed borrowed
shoes so my one sneak pair of sneakers I
did wear for certain events and I have
photos of them actually the original
sneakers are still in my closet in my
room I never got rid of them I haven't
worn them in like probably 6 or 7 years
but they're just in my closet I can't
drove one probably for the best that you
haven't worn them I come back I wouldn't
let you imagine what sort of mistake
they're in so at the actual event I
needed like lifting shoes and knee
sleeves and belts and all that stuff was
borrowed and like all my clothes were
like stolen like I mean it was just a
complete I was a complete like yard sale
of stuff so I got second place at this
event and I had beaten people who are
top three at the CrossFit Games and it
was a huge huge deal and the scoring was
all messed up so like in reality they
found out later that I had actually won
the event but it was too late to give me
prize money or anything like that which
I would changed my life
no prize money [ __ ] place no no it's
ten thousand for first that I would have
totally changed my lives well I would've
been like I would have been like that
would be like only money like I'd have
been like crazy yeah huh think about
that it's crazy so after that I did get
a bunch of sponsor they got like Pro
Connect was a protein sponsor this
clothing company started sponsoring me
all these other gyms you know we're like
yeah you could totally work at my gym I
got all these job opportunities so I
wanted moving to Los Angeles and I did
not like that experience like at all I
did not like living in LA I didn't like
living in the city especially Los
Angeles it was where I was at like I
obviously didn't have a lot of money it
was very poor and like just super grungy
dirty and the gym that I
working out at wasn't very they weren't
very known for being a very good gym
there were condoms
you know Rhonda Teasdale no he was kind
of he was kind of a badass at the time
where he was very in like controversial
type of person he wrote a big article
once about how like fat people were
ruining the world and like ruining the
gene pool and like okay yeah yeah this
guy this cousin tons so CrossFit really
hated him because he wrote all these
crazy controversial articles and he was
an amazing athlete actually get down at
retail several times and almost went to
the games as well but now you have you
know me linking up going to his gym I
start like coaching a ton of classes
start saving up dough and I wanted to
train more so I started getting more
into like personal training and I'll
never forget the first time I don't
think I'd ever made more than $25 an
hour in my life at that time and I'll
never forget having this kid come in he
was like an actor and he was getting
ready to be on an Apple commercial and
he wanted to he wanted to look look good
right and I'm like all right yeah well
you know you can come in you got to come
in like three four days a week and you
know we'll do this in this and I showed
him like what we would do like a
strength template and all this stuff and
he was all excited and so how much is it
in my mind I was like dude I would be so
happy if I just got like $50 but I
didn't have any money I'm like still
coming out of this hole of no money and
I'm like it's $100 a session and like I
really don't like to work with people
unless they buy at least like ten up
front because lets me know that you're
committed and I remember him just being
like yeah like no problem you know and
then after we got done talking he walked
away I'll never forget out I went inside
the bathroom and I just started like
screaming I was like oh my gosh Ain so
that feeling just like never went away
so I started just selling people on
personal training all the time and I was
like started getting really good at it
and then eventually after about a year I
had saved up sixty thousand dollars in
cash like I had paid for all my expenses
I had sixty thousand dollars saved where
you can see
$2,000 shoebox under the bed no I put it
in the bank oh okay okay
I wasn't like investing in her anything
like a seeing-eye savings account for
you so I wound up at one of these
competitions that I went to during that
time I met with this kid named Kenny
leverage and he was across what games
athlete and he was just like begging me
to come move down to Newport Beach where
he lived which is where I live now and
it's obviously a much different vibe
totally different place so I'm on the
beach now and it's more of like a town
type of feel like more like family like
and stuff it's not like grungy bums
running around the neighborhood type of
place like where I was in LA so
obviously I loved it here and he got me
a job at the gym that he worked at so I
moved and I was only I was only there
for huh I think I was there for like a
year and a half before I decided to open
my own gym so my time in LA and that
year and a half that was when I had
$60,000 so all of that time and I met
these two guys that I was personal
training at the time who looked like
bums by the way they looked like normal
total normal dudes they always even
sounded normal like I never heard
anything crazy come out of their mouth
and they just always asked me what I
wanted to do with my life and blah blah
blogs they always saw something
something in me that they just thought
that I had a little something extra than
the other coaches so I was like well I
would love to own my own gym but there's
so many around like at the time the
Orange County area which is where I live
we had like a record we had 16 gyms in
the area like in a small ten-mile radius
like not very much so to open a gym here
was like considered madness so I told
them that I'm like well I'd love to own
my own gym but there's 16 here and what
do you want me to do and he's like well
I think that the person sells the gym so
like I think that you would be fine
and I'm like I disagree I feel like
people come because their friends are
here or because it's the closest one so
if if that's all I have to work off of I
want to make sure that when you walk in
there's no way you walk out so if you
guys give me a million dollars I will
open a gym
they were like fine like it was nothing
and I was like okay it was it was it was
literally that that simple like today
and it was just like okay go find your
space go [ __ ] pimp it out and let's
go and I was like wow okay so like
within a couple weeks we had found this
face it wasn't even for rent they'd
cross that chalked in that I Ellen right
now was a real working gym at the time
and we gave them at the time they wanted
$200,000 to leave because they had put
$700,000 in like upgrades to the
building and they're like we'll leave
you to give us this much money and we're
like no we're not giving you a penny
more than like 50 grand so eventually
they took it we took over the space and
then I created what now is across the
chaulk and I did not need a million
dollars I needed like 250 grand was like
still more than I could spend pretty
much at the time but I did need money
for like salaries and pay and like what
if we didn't make money for a year like
a lot of different things but the gym is
like a legitimate million dollar gym
which at the time was completely unheard
of but after I opened my gym I was in
almost every single across a magazine
immediately like the way that it looked
and like the way that I was running it
and all this like was was completely
unheard of at the time what was
different about it when you walked in it
looked almost nicer than like an equinox
but it was like a functional fitness gym
I had all of the competition plates
lined up against the wall on a rig like
thirty thousand dollars in competition
plates which at the time you know doing
my due diligence of other gyms and what
they had and what they were offering
like everybody had at the time the
rubber plates
nobody was putting in these expensive
plates like if I put rubber plates in my
whole gym would've been seven grand and
everybody was all about starting in your
garage and then eventually going to a
small space and then a bigger space and
like going step by step by step and I
was always like under the impression the
most the most well the gyms that every
that was really doing well like all the
gyms
well you have like SoulCycle you have
Barry's bootcamp you have Ono whatever
you guys have by you but like their
their big franchise gems and they never
come out and they're like you know what
let's just start this soul cycle in a
garage and then if it gets bigger we're
gonna go to this small space and then if
that gets bigger well go to a really
nice space somewhere and see what
happens
they're like no let's just I can go to
the nice place now let's put 50 bikes in
there we're gonna fill it like how do
you feel when you walk into gym and
there's two rowers and four kettlebells
and you're like it's 200 hours a month
we're gonna do this and you're like what
it doesn't make any sense
so like that to me all these blew me
away and I was like if I ever get to
open a gym I'm never gonna do that that
seems absolutely ridiculous so you know
I I decked the whole gym out and all the
nicest stuff I had 10 assault bikes I
had 10 rowers I had [ __ ] like a tea
kettle bells all these dumbbells like
stacks of dumbbells like at any point
anybody in class could have any weight
they want and I would never have to
worry about not having enough equipment
which was always embarrassing as a coach
because you have a workout with an RX
weight and then like half the people
couldn't do it
do you remember well what do you
remember when the 22 and a half kilo
dumbbells came out was it 17 1 or 18 1
and there was like you've seen all these
videos going out online if someone with
that 15 kilo dumbbell with a couple of
plates duct-taped on at the end of them
yeah yeah that was ridiculous so like
also CrossFit really [ __ ] that up
though because like everybody in the
free world had like 45 pound dumbbells
but nobody had 50s and I was like even
now I have this giant stack of 45 and a
giant stack of 50s and I'm like do I
really need two stacks of a 5 pound
difference but yeah that was row trying
to make some money they probably had
tons of 50 pound dumbbells sitting
around it like what are we doing guys no
one's no one's using these 22 and a half
kilo dumbbells what can we do Dave May
is there any chance that you could yeah
Brittany thank you Ranchers there's Dave
Castro Justin we've got like a rogue
t-shirt for every day of the year
oh yeah my goal was to make it to the
CrossFit Games and wear a t-shirt that
says my mama don't like you and she
likes everybody and it has Dave Castro
Justin Bieber line yeah Dave Castro is
funny story Dave Castro was the second
ever podcast that I did so I got invited
Lee I got invited down to eighteen point
zero by Reebok they did that remember
that did you ever see that yeah yes so
the 18.0 announcement and I'm sitting
down with Dave and I've like I've done
one podcast before this right and I love
I love pocket I've been a guest or
whatever but I'd never done one before
and you sit down and Dan Bailey was
coming up after Dave so Dan Bailey was
number three and Dan's already met me
hey man how's it going this that and the
other and then Dave's kind of he's he's
kind of a bit intimidating to kind of
speak to and I'm really al didn't really
know how he's gonna go and then just
before we started tables I so what we're
doing here now that I'm about to record
a podcast that's I don't really do
podcasts I was that right okay well I'm
just gonna get you to count to five for
me please Dave if that's okay and I just
kind of steamrolled through that but and
then I asked him would I say would you
rather fight ten duck-sized horses or
one horse-sized duck and I was just get
think of to like try and lighten the
mood a little bit and asked him about
who would you not want to face out the
CrossFit Games in The Hunger Games and
he was like I don't know what that is I
was like it's kind of like battle royale
battle royale do you mean WWE and I was
like no Dave where've you been
do you not watch any movies yeah he
hasn't really been to a lot of places
he's not a he's not a happy man
so anyway he was it was interested in
the difference between him and done then
Dan comes out and dance just like super
funny super relaxed but yeah so yeah
you're in the gym you've opened the gym
you've got thirty thousand dollars of
weights plates and bars and all that
stuff yeah and I mean I probably spent
about a hundred grand on equipment one
hundred thousand dollars probably on
equipment and then I put a like I may be
another hundred thousand dollars into
like the build of the building just like
painting and changing things making it
nicer my bathrooms were like two hundred
and fifty thousand dollars but I didn't
have to do that there was the person
before us that was part of the that was
part of the money they wanted to get
back so now I have like theoretically
about a million dollar gym
and my first day open i had like a
hundred members and I didn't even do any
pre-sales I just like opened and
everybody came because during that time
I was posting on Instagram because
Instagram was just starting to get big
and I started posting like hey I just
bought 30 grand in Olympic lifting
plates here's that here's the space
before all the weights here's you know
where we are in town which is like a
really nice commercial area and
everybody else was in industrial areas
and like it was the first time somebody
was gonna go and spend like my rents
like eleven thousand dollars a month
it's crazy and everybody everybody
before that was spending like three four
thousand dollars in like a little garage
style space so I'm in this nice area
everybody sees the gym all painted and
pretty then they see the weights come in
and they see all these rigs and all this
stuff all the rowers all the bikes
they're like holy [ __ ] this place is
gonna be insane so without me knowing
everybody's putting in their 30-day
notice at all the gyms you know when
they're all like getting ready to come
and I have a video on my computer like
the first day I'm just packed and
everybody told me you know if you get a
hundred members in your first year
you're doing really good out of hundreds
my first day [ __ ]
but I'm so anal and I'm so like you know
I'm so grateful for this opportunity I
don't want to blow it you know my this
is this last year has been very
stressful for me you know a guy had a
lot of ups and downs like the last three
years really and it was very important
to me to have the right people there
like when it started I had zero coaches
I coached every single class every
single day for two months before I hired
my first coach what was the timetable so
5:00 a.m. was the first class and then
7:45 p.m. was the last one so I get home
I would get home at usually about 10:00
and then get back to the gym at about
4:00 a.m. so I would leave the gym at
10:00 by the time I actually went to bed
would be like midnight and then I wake
up at 4:00 sometimes I'd wake up at like
3:00 because I'd be nervous to wake up
at 4:00 and then before I knew it I was
only sleeping like three or four hours a
night for those whole two months and I
was like a complete zombie but there is
girl who had gone to regionals I'd met
her a few times and she kept emailing me
you know I really want to go on a coach
there and blah blah blah so I was like
alright well you know you come and let
me go see how you do and whatever so she
did a great job and I had to like watch
her every day for like a month so it
basically was like me still running all
the classes every day but I'd get to
like kind of sit off to the corner and
just you know get to write workouts and
do management stuff which I didn't
realize how much really went into it you
know I thought opening a gym was you
know you open it and you have this many
members and this is your expenses and
off you go it's not like that at all so
people always ask you to open a gym now
and I'm like please for the love of God
do not open a gym like you genuinely
just don't understand and I was so lucky
in my opportunity and like I'm something
tells me you don't have the same luck
that I had at that moment because just
like the height of CrossFit the height
of my career like the insanity of up by
what my gym looked like the fact that
Instagram was climbing at the time I had
so many things in my favor that people
just don't have now that for you to
replicate that is almost impossible but
and I was like the top trainer at the
gym I was at like everybody wanted to go
with me like the owner of that gym was
never there he didn't care about the gym
he didn't stop in like it was there was
no connection to him so when I left it
was just natural for them to come I
think like 40 people probably came from
the gym that I was at before and then
everybody else just saw us on Instagram
so that was like all kind of all going
on and during this whole situation I'm
still training for regionals and
everybody so on for no sleep at night
yeah and everybody still wanted to see
me go to the games and all that but the
year prior to this was when I actually
threatened to murder that judge in front
of everybody
yeah tell us that story this was before
the gym was open and this is while I'm
still saving money I understand it in
the future I'm probably gonna open a gym
and like my whole life before that time
I just
got done being homeless like all these
different factors like crosses my life
basically and I'm in this moment and I'm
doing a workout that is the one workout
at Regionals that I could not wait to do
and it was 2159 deadlifts at 3:15 and
box jumps at 30 inches I had done 21
deadlifts probably 10 seconds before
anyone else even got off the bar
cuz 3:15 to me at the time was nothing
like I had a 600 pound deadlift I was
probably the only person in CrossFit
they had a seconder found a look at the
time and 3:15 to me felt like 225 so I
fly through it I get all my box jumps
done I go back to the bar and now I just
start getting no rep like crazy like no
rep no rep no rep and there's parts of
it where the guys know repping mean he's
not even looking at me like you're me
and he's over here and he's like no rep
no rep and he's like looking at the head
judge and I'm like you're not even
watching me work out this is ridiculous
like was it for extension is that what
the criticism was it was for bouncing
they said I was balancing the weights
and you can watch the video on YouTube
it's all over the place and I'm just the
weight is very very light to me so I'm
just going up and down very very fast so
it looks like I'm bouncing it and it's
the first year they had ever had
competition plates and competition
plates don't really bounce at all in
general so in the moment I'm like
freaking out I can feel that cuz the
year before that I got in fourth at
Regionals and this was my year like I
was gonna go to the games a hundred
percent even with all that I got dead
last in that event right because I
freaked out I tell the judge in the
middle of the workout dude I'm gonna
[ __ ] kill you you're like you're
ruining my life a lot of people like to
sit like to remember that I'm gonna
[ __ ] kill you part but they don't
understand that I said you're gonna
you're ruining my life after that
because like I can feel like everything
bobsled skeleton being homeless owning
that gym like not owning that gym
working at that gym that I hated like
not having any money stealing everything
is like in that moment and I'm like I'm
gonna go to the cross the games and
everything's gonna be fine and he was
taking it away from me in that moment
and the only thing I could think of is
like dude I'm gonna [ __ ] kill you
like you're ruining my life
and I guess I like screamed it and
scared the [ __ ] guy and he was like
freaking out and then basically they had
to make an example out of me and like
afterwards like dead capture comes over
and like publicly humiliates me and like
points to me and tells me that I'm a
terrible person all over CrossFit they
exploited it all over the website like
Ryan Fischer is you know completely out
of line and maniac and blah blah blah I
got last place in the event obviously
because I didn't they would never give
me a rep so eventually just like gives
like a hundred dead list instead of 45
and then I wouldn't sign the paper at
the end it was just like a giant giant
[ __ ] ordeal huh so after that moment
I was considered the maniac for CrossFit
and then opening my gym actually seemed
even crazier at the time because now
there are 16 gyms in the area I'm the
complete maniac guy that probably nobody
wants to go to his gym coz you look him
up and he looks like Johnny McEnroe he's
like [ __ ] smashing tennis racquets
everywhere so like huh like my mom was
like begging me she's like Ryan like
your name is not good like you know you
shouldn't open a gym and all these
different things but you know it worked
out you know and and and the gym was
doing well so with all that being said
the height for me to go back to
regionals was pretty big everybody
wanted to see me compete again and they
wanted to see me kind of overcome the
odds and that was my thought I'd wear
that Justin Bieber sure my mama don't
like you and she likes everyone cuz my
mom [ __ ] hates the guy and she
actually called him one day and told him
how much she hated him your mum wrung
Dave test room yeah because after the
whole regional event like he like
literally ruined my name like it was so
bad and I was like such a good
crossfitter and everybody just everybody
still to this day remembers me as the
crazy person
till they need me they're like man I
thought you were gonna be totally
different like you're actually really
nice and bah-bah-bah everywhere always
thought you're insane
so she got his phone number at one point
somehow and was like I can't believe
you've ruined my son's life and like
blah blah blah and like all this stuff
so I just was like man if I make it to
the game Sunday I want to have this
shirt that has like the Justin Bieber
little quote on it and I and it'd just
be so funny I love the fact that mums
get in to that sort of a thing you know
I don't know if you watched the Conor
McGregor fight this weekend but at the
end of the fight so he's just smashed
Donald Cerrone in 40 seconds right and
Donald Cerrone E's grandmother comes
over and that has a word with Connor and
it's like it's so funny even at the
absolute top flight of the sport or you
know regionals this huge event Conor
McGregor biggest fighter on the planet
it's like you still got once at
someone's grandmother let the global
wags a finger in your face you're like
oh [ __ ] that's his grandmother it's hard
as nails but you probably still like
weirdly intimidated by the grandmother
yeah probably
I could imagine for sure he looks like
he said some nice things story so yeah I
mean all that stuff was kind of going on
through my head and in my life and it
was a crazy crazy time for sure and I'll
never forget all that but Dave Castro he
didn't go away after that for me when I
was opening my gym he tried to take it
away from me
Oh cuz I I wanted to call the gym
because they wouldn't accept any of my
names for the gym I really wanted talk
and I wouldn't accept it and I really
wanted this other name like diesel I
wanted like sweat I want to call my gym
CrossFit sweat all these different
things they wouldn't accept anything and
I was like [ __ ] this you guys suck like
I'm gonna call my gym CrossFit untitled
cuz you guys won't even settle on a
title and untitled actually means by
definition that it's beyond a title and
that you know it was like this really
interesting definition for what it
actually meant and I didn't want to be
associated with CrossFit almost at that
time anyway
so someone I had wrote about this on
Facebook and I was like I want to call
my gym
CrossFit untitled cuz it means this and
this and this and this and across so
it's never been really good to me anyway
and then someone screenshot it and sent
it to Dave and then Dave writes me an
email he says you will never own across
the gym you know so you can get you can
get rid of this this name that you want
to call it and you know basically go
[ __ ] yourself so I'm like alright well
there goes that I guess I'm just opening
a regular gym now
so I write to Cappy Glassman which is
Greg Glassons wife at the time and I say
hey you know what I'm actually not gonna
be opening a gym apparently Dave is
actually really upset with me you know I
don't have the greatest you know history
with you guys and maybe it's best I just
move on and just open my gym as a
regular gym and we just forget this
whole across the thing then she's like
oh wait a minute you know we do have
this one choc contract it's been it's
been taken for six months but no one's
ever opened the gym so maybe you can
have that one but you have to pay the
affiliate fee like right now and I was
like done I've been fighting for that
name for almost a hundred emails we went
back and forth 88 emails and every email
that I wrote had five names on it so for
my gym so if you can multiply 88 times
five that's how many need for food and
ice yeah that's how many names that I
suggested before we landed on choc it
was a nightmare and then even since then
Dave will be in the area and he'd never
stopped by my gym he always stops by
this one gym it's like a few miles away
and he stops there multiple times yeah
he always takes photos like in his
affiliate in the affiliates and like you
never go to the same affiliate more than
once like you'd go to a different one
but he's been to the same one multiple
times now you probably because he's got
his one favorite that's interesting yeah
and he never comes to mind so it's funny
but regardless after all that the gym I
I went to regionals again it wasn't what
I thought it was gonna be obviously I
had a lot more scrutiny on me for
judging like there was more judges
watching me and so they didn't want they
didn't bun you after the they didn't ban
me on a [ __ ] kill you
my life that wasn't yeah man but it was
worthy of public denouncement yeah and
they really wanted to see me freak out
again so they tried very very hard and I
got drug tested all the time like it was
ridiculous how much I got drug test like
every couple months but none game
exactly yep and then my buddy who was
across at games athlete was like never
getting drug tested and I was like this
is ridiculous like you've gone to the
games three times and you've maybe been
drug tested one time and it was at
Regionals I get drug tested just like
sitting in my house like [ __ ] reading
a book you know what I mean like it's
ridiculous
so I was always getting drug tests I had
that body that everybody wanted to fail
everybody's like this guy is definitely
on drugs and I'm like no I actually just
I really do eat insanely well if I never
ever cheat you guys are always out
partying and eating [ __ ] doughnuts
and [ __ ] and I'm actually only eating
chicken broccoli so so I just looked the
way that I did but anyway after all that
the gym was picking up more and it was
something that I started just really
pour my heart into and it was I was
starting to realize that you know maybe
I was maybe meant to be a business
person and I had come so close to so
many things right like like we had like
we had talked about in so many different
sports and business for me didn't really
feel like I had to ever win anything it
was just kind of you know how big can I
grow this thing how many people can I
help like there's a lot of things that
make you bigger but there's no like
qualification process really you know
you have to evaluate yourself and make
sure that you have all your look all
your ducks in a row if you will but yeah
you can you can go as far as you want
and there really is no first place or
whatever it's just where are you
comfortable going and during that time
I didn't like when Jim started small and
and they and they started to build like
I said I wanted to come out guns blazing
I also didn't like that Jim's would put
their workouts on their website I always
thought it was weird like every CrossFit
gym you could just go to their website
and see their workout like that was
totally normal I could I could look at
any CrossFit gym in the world there are
thousands of gyms I could look up their
email address or their website go to
their page and I can see the workout
steal the program singled every single
day right
so I was like this is so weird I am NOT
doing that so I never did but the gym
kept getting more followers and
Instagram and people would be like every
once in a while I would post a workout
that we did and they'd be like dude that
workout looks awesome or what are you
guys doing in there like the gym looks
amazing like you have so many members
like and I just opened and like all this
stuff and about three years of this went
on where people would ask me to work out
I got to the point where like I'll never
forget I had a phone call from someone
in Norway asking me what what the
workout was for the gym that day I was
like you're from Norway like why one I'm
probably spending money on this phone
call but I don't want any spend if you
reverse the child you see I missed a
person from Oslo and like why do you
care that much about the workout and I
started to realize that I made workouts
much much different than everybody else
I didn't really spend time looking at
other people's websites but when I
realized what I was making I realized it
was much much different and I had a drop
in who this lady would drop into gyms
all over the world for work and she was
like this is my favorite gym it's the
best program I've ever done you really
should put these workouts online and
charge people and I was like alright
I'll give it a go you know and I was
like I'll charge everybody like a
hundred bucks a month or something and
my friend was like no I might not want
to do that that's kind of a lot like
maybe like twenty dollars something
really cheap and I'm like twenty dollars
you know how long it takes me to do this
like you're out of your mind and then
all my friends were like well you're
probably gonna get like a you know you
might get like a hundred people that buy
it and I'm like well that would be cool
I guess
I guess I could settle for that extra
$2,000 a month I was making in like
$4,000 a month of the time like that was
my salary for the gym was 4,000 I'm like
about a hundred people on this for $20
I'd be stoked so I make it $20 the first
week that it's out
I made $4,000 and I was like
holy [ __ ] I was like I just doubled I
just doubled my salary and I was like
this is insane so I still didn't even
market it because I was kind of
embarrassed to be the guy who didn't go
to the CrossFit Games and I'm marketing
cost at programming you know like
because you have like Invictus and like
you know
rich Froning which he didn't even have
mayhem at the time but Invictus had a
bunch of athletes and they had
programming they didn't even charge for
it and then like comp train with Ben
Bertrand he wasn't charging for it and
like now all of a sudden you have
CrossFit chalk which is the guy who
threatened to murder someone who wants
20 dollars for his programming it's like
it's like do you don't know about all
this and I'm like well [ __ ] I just paid
$4,000 I think a lot of people really
whether whether I'm this person who
murders people or not people really like
my workouts so the good workouts here a
couple months went by and it went from
like I was making $4,000 a month off of
it to like $10,000 a month and I was
like wow like maybe I should market this
thing maybe I should actually talk about
it and I still like was like hesitant so
I would I would do a couple posts like
hey I have this programming in blah blah
blah if you guys want to follow it and
before I knew it dude like even just
casually would start bumping fifteen
twenty thousand dollars a month and I'm
like holy [ __ ] this is insane
you know like I'm making five six times
what I'm making in the gym and it's
really not any extra work it's the
workouts that I'm already doing but the
workouts kept getting more stressful to
make for me because now I'm like well
now it's not just my gym members I want
to please I want all of these people to
look at these workouts and be like [ __ ]
that's dope
you know even still like I've owned the
gym now for six years I'm the only
person who's ever made the workouts and
it went from taking me a couple hours to
taking me like an entire 24 hour day to
make workouts now because I'm so like I
need them to be [ __ ] insane and now I
have free programs it started off as
just CrossFit and then I added the sweat
program to it which is the conditioning
program because I started to see that a
lot of people weren't really stoked on
CrossFit all the time and they
they still wanted to come to the gym and
do that that circuit like training but
they didn't want to lift all the heavy
weights so I created a sweat program and
then a lot of people were like wait what
do I do when I travel so I started
making this thing called the daily D
which is the daily dumbbell program and
it's just dumbbells jump rope pull-up
bar that's it so now I have these three
different programs I want all of them to
be awesome so I'm making like 21
workouts every Sunday for the week and
it gets me pretty hard but anyway I
started marketing the program more and
it got to the point where it was making
you know make almost like seven figures
in a year now on just online program on
that and then it kind of just took off
on its own I even still I barely ever
talked about it like if you follow me on
social media you might seem you like
posts a repost someone's thing and it
says okay you can fly but if you want to
join I talk about it more often on the
choc Instagram put on mine it's like
very very rare mm-hmm I don't like to be
very salesy with it and like now it's at
the point where people just talk about
it and it kind of just flows but then
the challenge is started where I like I
wanted to make you know things cooler to
people in the gym so I started doing the
nutrition challenges and then it was the
same thing people wanted to do the
challenges and then I opened it up to
everybody so then you have the
challenges you had that my knees getting
worse and worse because it was when I
was about 30 it was when my knee was
really bad and I was - I was pretty much
deciding if I was ever gonna compete
again because my name is since I was
like 27 my knee had been bothering me I
had a really bad snowboard accident and
tore my ACL had full reconstruction in
my knee act or like everything in there
and throughout like all the lifting
through bobsled and skeleton and
CrossFit doing pistols and squatting
every single day and doing crazy [ __ ]
and running marathons and all sorts of
stuff my knee was just shot and even now
my knee is just like totally gone so I
started training differently in my own
training and I started bringing in a lot
more bodybuilding stuff but I loved the
sweat of CrossFit and I loved like the
bikes and the assault bikes and just
straight just dying so I started
mixing together some old ideologies I
found in some old articles from this guy
named Pat O'Shea from the 70s and it's
it's kind of the original methodology
that Greg Glassman took over and created
what we know of as CrossFit today so I
started taking a lot of these things I
mix it with bodybuilding and I started
creating this thing called
high-intensity interval bodybuilding
because I love that term hit training it
was like the most googled term and I
said well how can I spin off that so
I'll say all right well I'm gonna take
everything I know about CrossFit and
everything I love about bodybuilding I'm
gonna mix it two together and I'm gonna
call it high intensity interval
bodybuilding I'm gonna call it him
instead of hit and then that [ __ ]
thing exploded so I kind of like
stumbled upon everything and when people
ask me like how everything actually
happened I tell them that I actually
just wanted people to stop emailing me
and stop contact so like the CrossFit
program was just people for to stop
emailing me and stop asking about the
work I was so I made that the nutrition
programs were all because people kept
asking me if they could do what we were
doing and I was like all right well I
need to figure out how to stop all these
emails and then people asked me what I
was doing with my programming and I was
like aren't wall this is what I'm doing
so here you go here's an e-book you can
buy that I was like my first ebook and
then all that [ __ ] just took off and it
was really just a way to get people to
stop talking to me and then low and
behold I become a podcast there now I
talked for a living oh yeah I had a
podcast I did a podcast quite a while
ago that was about a reality TV thing
that I went on and it was precisely the
same it was the fact that loads of
people say hey man so what was what's it
actually like on love island and I was
like right I'm gonna do this podcast and
now for the rest of time all that I ever
need to do is send them one youtube link
it's like they go that's an hour and
I've just scaled the the response and
one thing I really want to delve into is
what makes your programming different do
you have some principles that you stick
to you know there'll be a lot of coaches
listening a lot of guys from the UK a
lot of guys from the US and they'll be
thinking [ __ ] I want it I want to
upgrade the way that I program for my
gym I want to make the the members feel
gassed when they step in it's gonna be
different what is it so yeah
and I actually just made a video about
this on my Instagram
yesterday I loved you saw it or not look
at my kitchen no notes below so
basically I'll never forget my first
time that I genuinely wanted to get good
at making workouts I don't remember the
age that I was at but I know I was in
college and I remember the movie 300
came out and it wasn't just Gerard
Butler who was all wrecked like you know
you know the main character it was
everybody in the movie like everybody
was ripped and everybody was like what
the [ __ ] are these people doing yeah
yeah it was the first movie that where
everybody was ripped and everybody was
like going crazy I was on the cover of
Men's Health magazine and everything
traced back to this guy named marked
white and marked white owned a gym
called Jim Jones which is another famous
kind of branch of gyms well it's
actually only one gym but they do
seminars and stuff kind of like CrossFit
to interject there sorry anyone that's
listening who knows who marked white and
mr. Blevins his partner are they have a
seminar in the UK in the middle of April
and I finally got a reply of Blevins
himself and I might be able to get him
on while he's over here which would be
really really cool so that before yeah
he's an interesting guy if you've not
checked out the dissect podcast which is
their thing then they're cool guys
they're underground the kind of
anti-market in I really I really like
the vibe dude I wanted to go to their
gym so bad I got the time in when I was
living in Utah you would see Jim Jones
shirts but you never knew where the gym
was and when you went to the website it
actually said like we will not disclose
location because we are by referral and
you have or if it's not by referral you
need to tell us why you want to work out
here and like they only accepted people
to work out there it was the most it was
so badass I was obsessed I was like I
have to work out here and like I would
send them emails and like my responses
were never good enough and like it was
ridiculous I was like [ __ ] this place
you know like this is insane
yeah so make him was out three hundred
men's health yeah so I start looking
into what he was doing and he I wound up
actually meeting one of his trainers
because I never could work out at his
gym and I started asking them about you
know what they do and what their
what their secret sauce is in
buh-buh-bah and they start talking about
this thing called IWT training interval
weight training and I looked that up and
that was basically invented by a guy
named Pat O'Shea in the 70s so I what
you if you look up now like the
principles behind Jim Jones you can just
google it and it talks about IWT and Pat
O'Shea and basically a lot of the stuff
that they were making was he was the
first person Pat O'Shea in the 70s
making these like high-intensity
interval workouts with compound lifts so
I know all this information at that time
I'm going to school through exercise
physiology I understand the body when
I'm done with school like I'm pretty
smart I wind up being on the bobsled
team I went up doing 10 years of
CrossFit I went up owning my gym for six
years all these different factors that
come into play I trained tons of
different athletes football players
wrestlers UFC fighters all sorts of
stuff and I come into like one
conclusion right over time we're all
gonna get injured at some point if we're
gonna be sport specific if we're all
gonna do CrossFit we're gonna get
injured at some point we're all read the
UFC we're all gonna get injured at some
point if we all just do bodybuilding
we're probably gonna get injured at some
point but a lot lower risk because
there's not a lot of like rapid movement
and stuff like that more like an overuse
injury than anything but all of us are
in this weird place where we all
mentally like to be [ __ ] we all like
to be in this crazy ridiculous
conditioning base where like we just
like to die right and that's why we're
listening to this podcast probably
everybody who's part of this has at some
point been on the ground full covered in
sweat and all these other athletes they
like doing football and you have seen
all these things that there's a lot of
grind to it so I I mixed together the
old-school IWT stuff the things I liked
about CrossFit the things I didn't like
about CrossFit I got rid of right in my
in my training that you don't see a lot
of overhead squats you don't see a lot
of handstand push-ups you don't see a
lot of muscle ups I have them as
advanced options for people who are
think they really want to be good at
CrossFit like microscopy programming
Advanced Options almost every day and I
like to fancy like both Krauts you know
the competitor and the person who's just
doing this to look good
and they just love functional training
so that's what makes mine so different
and I also a big fan of maximizing my
time like I always thought it was weird
that people spent 15 minutes doing a
clean and jerk and then they would have
a 15 20 minute conditioning piece so I'm
like well why don't we do an imam what
we're doing like the other day I we'd
literally just two days ago my my
workout for the day was on the first
minute you do 15 burpees and on the
second minute you do 3 clean and jerks
and then after three minutes you go to
to clean and jerks and then after three
minutes you go to one clean and jerk but
you're always doing 15 burpees so in
like a 20-minute window you had done 150
burpees and you had built up to a 1 at
max clean and jerk and in other days
I'll do something where it's like a
front squat and a rope climb or like a
front squat and like a lateral lunge
like a leg superset or I'll do like the
first piece will be will do like 5 heavy
strict press into like 10 dumbbell bent
over rows into 50 double unders min at
rest and you keep going through that
sequence for 15 20 minutes so it's like
a whole compounding superset so I'm a
huge fan of doing super sets and the
reason for that is people are here
because they want to do a workout that
takes limited time and gets them out the
door but you're my responsibility when
you walk out the door when you when you
tell someone where you workout I want
you to be proud of where you work out
and when you say my name and my facility
I want to make sure that we're doing the
best that we can for you to look the
best you can because if you look
mediocre I'm gonna feel mediocre when
you tell people you work out of my gym
so I'm not gonna just give you some
little 15 minute piece I'm gonna give
you like a 15 20 minute compounding
piece with a bunch of other stuff and
then we're gonna do the same
conditioning that everybody else does
but in my own format even when I think
about conditioning I think of way
different factors and other people I
can't stand when someone has the
conditioning component and there's
something in there that slows you down
well I know there's like there's like 15
blah blah maybe it's like 15 wall balls
15 toes of our 15 power cleans at one
third
five or something like that right it's
like all right well 15 well balls I get
15 tows a bar you're not gonna have very
many people hanging on the bar for 15
reps so let's go ahead and take that
down to like maybe seven or eight and
then power cleans like 15 there's kind
of a lot in that aspect because you're
gonna be sitting there doing one at a
time let's say it's a ten-minute amrap
now you only got like three rounds of
this work out like for most people right
so let's go you know 15 wall balls seven
toes of our five power cleans and then
I'll go rx+ option and I'll do 15 wall
balls ten toes of our seven power cleans
and I'll make it one 55 you know
something like that rather than just
write that original workout I'll write
two different versions of it and I think
that it gives it the stimulus that it
needs for both crowds
what's the cell adaptations that you're
seeing from this sort of a workout
because there'll be some people you know
you got power lifter who's who's
listening or a weightlifter who's
listening and they think well you're
gonna you're gonna drop down that top
end power you're not going to be able to
do a true 1 rep max if you got to do 15
burpees in between each round or you've
got someone who's maybe more in an
amount of structural side of things I
think I think well you're not going to
be pulling so much on the rower if you
got to do war balls or deadlifts or
whatever in-between so what the sort of
adaptations that you see so that's kind
of like what Pat O'Shea's thing was back
then was that you could actually lift
maximal loads even with the conditioning
opponent mixed in and I just did you
know Wendler have you ever heard of the
Wendler template which 5:31 method I
just did a Wendler 531 method granted
I've had this Tim for six years I've had
members online for about two and a half
now and I created my first Wendler
template that was mixed with IWT format
from Patterson from the 70s so the first
week for instance you have your
deadlifts it's 60
sixty-five cents 65 75 85 percent like
on your first week of lifts there's a
little bit heavier percentage on week
two and three and then week four is your
recovery so your even your even though
grabbing the D loads in there as in 531
yep so the first part like on on week
one of this particular template I did
every four minutes by four rounds so I
put a time cap on it and then I also
added a conditioning component in so I
did every four minutes by four rounds I
did forwarded me to run by in and then
your deadlifts at that percentage that
you were supposed to do that day and
then the next week I did a 20 Cal
assault bike buy-in and then your
percentages through deadlifts and then
week three I did a 500-meter row buy-in
and then your percentage for that for
the deadlifts for that week and that's
the max out week so the first two weeks
I did every four minutes by four rounds
and then the last week I did every five
minutes by five rounds I added an extra
round at an extra minute of rest I got
more PRS than I've ever seen in my
entire years of owning the gym online
program I mean there's literally gold
stars on my water fly account like just
butter like just ringing straight across
the board so people are using the
conditioning what I think it is is a lot
of people under warm-up so you have
these long conditioning pieces mixed in
with the lifting and it's actually
warming them up to the point where
they're actually doing things right for
themselves and then also the stress of
time is actually letting them do the
lift in an appropriate manner cuz a lot
of people will either take too much time
off right they sit around and talk to
their bodies for five six minutes and do
the lift and its heaviest [ __ ] all of a
sudden or they don't take enough time
off and they're lifting it too soon so
now when you have this window you want
to be at the end of the window on time
right because you want you're like oh my
god I'm pretty tired from the row or the
run or whatever I'm gonna wait so they
wind up waiting and they wind up without
knowing it resting just the right amount
of time to do that left so for me it's
actually a really smart way of doing it
because if you know if you knew exactly
what you were doing every single day you
probably wouldn't be coming into a
classroom setting right
you're probably there because you want
some guidance so I'm trying to figure
out the best way to guide people and
when people find my programming they
realize that I'm really doing it in such
a way that I'm maximizing the amount of
time they're there I'm maximizing their
strength gains their results all these
different things off of just stealing a
whole bunch of ideologies and just
making them one very different to
CrossFit when you think about CrossFit
especially traditional sort of CrossFit
stuff like it's very different well I'll
do high-intensity interval bodybuilding
days like the stuff that I write in my
ebooks I'll do days of that stuff in the
middle of a week that's like very
CrossFit e and I'll just have it one day
where we kind of do a bodybuilding
circuit but it's in a conditioning
format and not everybody loves it for
sure like they're there to do strict
CrossFit but not everyone's getting hurt
all the time you know like I have a very
very low rate of people getting injuries
and it's because we spend time doing
like isolated movements on certain
muscle groups and letting those muscles
get stronger so that when you're doing a
dynamic portion of that lift at some
point with those muscle groups they're
not gonna get hurt
this is not like me but my my torn bicep
like that's probably overuse from a lot
of years of doing hundreds and hundreds
of thousands of muscle ups and thousands
of snatches and you know just a ton of
different things there's not a whole lot
of people now that I know who absolutely
love CrossFit you know so the gym that I
trainer has eight hundred members you
would absolutely love it man it's like a
playground for fitness like 800 800
members yeah Reebok CrossFit Tyneside in
the north of England is Alico certified
Alico weights placed in bars calibrated
the comp plates the weightlifting plates
the powerlifting little steel plates all
the bumpers like a 60 70 foot rig in two
rooms it's it's just it's beautiful we
they're an open gym yeah is there an
open gym six a.m. until 9:00 p.m. every
day except for weekends and you can
always open gym there's always open gym
some of the classes class size tops out
about 40 40 people and yeah Jordan
interestingly the guy who owns that he
went through like I'm gonna get this
wrong he's gonna kill me but I think he
went through that's seven sites before
this one so he
was the first version of the gym owner
that you described the star in a studio
move up to a slightly bigger studio than
a garage then under an arch then a
industrial unit slightly bigger industry
and now he's got something underneath a
carpet shop the whole basement
underneath the carpet shop and there's a
full body building side to it there's a
full weight lift inside and how that's
so cool it's legit I'll send you some
I'll send you some videos on email and
sometimes it's it's beautiful right
um but with that even I see now in those
classes I think the removal of regionals
has played quite a lot into this but
people aren't in love with CrossFit I
think that in love with the sweat
they're in love with the community
they're in love with a lot of the things
that CrossFit really brought together
and created as a community but you know
those you're right there in the overhead
squat workout the real high skill under
load and fatigue workouts where you know
even the best athletes the most robust
athletes that are in the gym know I'm
probably dicing with death a little bit
here with regards to maybe where my
shoulder position is or maybe where my
lower back feels at the moment or webbot
maybe how my knee feels at the moment or
something know people doing like
deadlifts running like heavy deadlift
like coupled with running coupled with
box jumps stuff like that you're like
[ __ ] man like you know there's something
risky going on here a little bit and I
wonder how much you can sacrifice on
that pure CrossFit side you know there
golden era 2009 2010 programing CrossFit
sacrifice on that and then get back in
terms of safety get back in terms of you
know the hypertrophy response which is
whatever anyone who say that they do
CrossFit and don't want to be an
unbelievable condition is lying to
themselves in line of the people they're
talking to yeah I can't stand that [ __ ]
they're like I just I just really want
to feel good and you know whatever and
I'm like you're telling me that you
don't want to look better there's no
[ __ ] way you know what I mean like
there's just no way like everybody wants
to look good you know what I mean and I
think that I think that's it that's a
big reason people like my programming
too is because I do some of that
bodybuilding stuff in there I am all
about people looking good right like
when you say my name you say my gym I
want you to look good
so that is a thing that I definitely
concentrate on and I don't think it
takes an exercise physiologist or an
athlete who's been competing for ten
years to look at a CrossFit workout and
say that's [ __ ] dumb like why am I
gonna do 21:59 of overhead squats and
something else as fast as I probably can
like an overhead squat is absolutely
100% meant to be like concentrated on
like making sure you're in the right
position making sure you're not just
just doing something you know what I
mean like even snatches like when in the
world have we ever done 30 snatches for
time like in history it's always been
like you never see a weightlifter do
more than five maybe at most and even
those guys when they get older they're
[ __ ] limping around and they're all
[ __ ] up and we're doing 30 sometimes a
hundred in a workout right like if it's
lighter I'm saying thirty eyes in terms
of like Isabel like Isabel is a workout
but it's a lot of impact on your joints
and your cartilage and all the stuff on
your body and I know that CrossFit this
year really wanted to make it they want
to get back to old school style and
really like come back to the roots of
like why'd Greg Glassman originally
started it and then they [ __ ] throw
pistols in the open and I was like what
the [ __ ] is this because that's another
movement that should be done like slowly
and methodically not like fast and like
yeah you can do it slow and methodically
but you're going to get last place so
but look at me Iser
look at Regionals when when everyone's
chests everyone was pop in the chest
yeah you know that was at 2018 that was
my last regional I competed in okay but
you came out of it with the chest still
attached yep yeah but a lot people eat
they say that everybody who tore was
like potentially on steroids so I was
like alright I passed again touch yeah
interesting there was a couple of power
lifters I'm friends with and they said
that PEC tear is like a root one
identifier of someone who is on peds
especially when they so they're going
into the squat bench deadlift right but
yeah you're totally right like there is
some stuff I just think that's dumb like
it just doesn't really work I was
talking to dr. stuart mcgill back
mechanic so good friend of mine i went
and stayed with him in canada last year
and i was talking to him and he said he
once saw a cross for athlete who had
nine bulging disks i think the total
number of vertebral bodies that you have
is seventeen so it's like more than half
of the gaps between and that includes
like all the the [ __ ] that's right up
here right in the back your neck like
more than fifty percent of and he this
was just compounded over time and you
think what the what the [ __ ] is going on
here dude i remember one of my first
probably my third or fourth regional
event we had to do a three rep max
overhead squat off the ground do you
remember that yeah yeah it was the first
overhead squat in history that we ever
had to do but we also didn't have a rack
so we had to clean it throw it on our
back then pop it up dude people were
getting so [ __ ] up trying to throw it
on their back i'm like and have you ever
done so many handstand push-ups in your
life that was just like one example
here's another one you ever done ever
done so many handstand push-ups i gonna
work out let's say you did a hundred
where your neck is like [ __ ] up yep
like i don't think we should do kipping
handstand push-ups ever and then i also
don't think that we should be doing I
don't even think we should even be doing
handstand push-ups to be honest like
there's presses I think are such a great
movement
there's no need I mean I think if you're
doing strict handstand push-ups and
you're doing them correctly I think
they're okay but most of the time it's
for time so like even if it's strict
you're gonna [ __ ] hit and it's like
why are we doing this I don't understand
like I walked away if there's so many no
half an inch shorter than when I walked
into it I mean how cool would it be if
the cross the games was just like a
one-mile run for time you know like a
foreigner meter sprint like all the max
lips like and and a few conditioning
workouts I had a whole bunch of you know
pull-ups and toes a bar and [ __ ] a net
and maybe a swim and like a bike and
stuff like that but like general events
like what's wrong with that there's
really nothing wrong like I know and you
can you can vary them a little bit like
maybe one year it's a 5k run and the
other year it's a mile and the other
year it's
like an 800 meter sprint or whatever
like basic track events and then you
know basic lifting some power lifting
some a little bit of gymnastics work
that's not like devastating to your body
but there's a better way to do it
it's not a sufficient and since then
it's not a sufficiently exciting
spectacle for the for the people that
are there to watch do you think it can
be dude if you had all your favorite
CrossFit athletes doing a 400-meter
sprint for time I would love to watch
that that would be fun that would be fun
oh like a 2k like a 2k row yeah to Cairo
or a mile run [ __ ] a 500 meter road
would be amazing to watch just because
like people handsome ii skid in the cone
say would you use all over the place
they would be dying or you seem like the
inch the indoor indoor cycling where
they go around the circle like you get
everybody like that would be [ __ ] rad
fully gust yeah yeah I'd be awesome I
wouldn't know how much sort of CrossFit
set its stall out because it has been
going so long and there is this sense
right that you got to do more better
different harder faster stronger all
this year each year I wonder if there is
a risk there of things getting too
intense thing this constant requirement
to one-up the year before you know this
year we're gonna let the audience get
involved this year we're gonna get an
octopus to pick the balls out of the
thing and he's gonna tell us what the
work has gonna be you know I mean I
don't I don't know I it's it's hard for
me because I always feel like the last
like two or three years I'm like man
cross that's getting smaller and smaller
and smaller like I feel like the the
excitement level of someone to do
CrossFit in my gym is getting less and
the people just want to come in and do
this like crazy workout kind of is
getting less and less and I keep
thinking that CrossFit's getting less
but there's still just as many people
who want to go walks across at games and
buy all the CrossFit [ __ ] online we're
just not seeing them every day but I I
keep thinking at this rate I'm like they
have to stop all this like CrossFit
Games has to stop they have to be
spending an enormous amount of money for
the games and all these things where
it's it's not a lucrative scenario for
them anymore and I keep thinking it's
going to happen and it hasn't happened
yet
so I take you know the Machine keeps on
moving man it's interesting because
you've got CrossFit as a sport
competitive sport and you've got
CrossFit as a training methodology right
and there's nothing else no one says I'm
training UFC they say like I'm training
other people that don't know what they
do you might say that but they say I'm
training MMA you know like I think that
it's the fact that you have CrossFit as
a competitive sport is one thing but the
more GPP kind of foundations of why
Glassman created CrossFit is something
else and you're totally right anyone who
follows is it at CrossFit health I think
if you followed that on Instagram it's
like they've got models of a old ladies
front room and some 60 year old guy
bending over the two gallon milk jug
like doing bent over rows with the two
gallon milk jug because it's the setting
this stall out it's like look we're
getting back to GPP we're getting back
to the fact that this just makes you
better at life fitness for life not life
for fitness and it's it's interesting
man I wonder I wonder where it's gonna
go look right I could honestly man I
could go on further
I could keep I could dig back into this
if you've got time I'd love to get you
back on at some point soon I want to
delve into a million other things but
we've got a percent we've done an hour
and a half man and it's like no such
thing is knee going to work I just start
working oh yeah well this is part of
work right look um what can people go
they want to check out some of your your
ebooks and your platforms and stuff why
should they go they could probably find
everything on my Instagram which is Ryan
fish ry ANF is CH and I have one of
those little link trees in my bio or has
a connection to pretty much everything
or if you want to follow just strict
strictly the gym stuff it's just
CrossFit chalk on Instagram we have
across the chaulk calm and then my
personal website is Jim Ryan calm which
is g ym r wa an see where I did there
kind of took the Jim Jonestown a deal
yeah but then also like everything for
me started with a gym so has some I have
some secret underlying yeah yeah it's
kind of cool yeah so man it's been it's
been absolutely awesome thanks so much
for your time
no problem again soon
sir
[Music]